did you write this song from the dumpers
point of view yeah it's a breakup song
that's not how a breakup song works
songs never about the dumper I'm Sarah
this is Pierce we're songwriters guys
I'm loving the song you two are killing
it it's gonna be a big hit on MTV
another get with the times we have
already Spotify I just know what I had
to work with you guys like buh doo buh
collab with you guys in this song now
that's a model of a yeah like this is
the biggest thing we've ever done in our
lives do you have any pointers for us
get out while you're young let me get
this straight you wanted to feature
every musical genre that has ever been
yeah you wanted in one song yeah but
keep it simple
these kids have oh it's under their belt
and that is a winning stream
yeah real drag to see it in this is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and I'm
completely blowing it
we're blowing up
we're a team with our powers combined we
do the work of one songwriter
I have a new single coming out you can
all get it very soon at your local
Spotify
you